WAS WASHINGTON, D.C., BUT THE
EFFECTS COULD BE FELT ALL OVER.
CORRESPONDENT GARRETT TENNEY
LOOKS AT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE TOOK TO THE STREETS THIS
PAST WEEKEND TO PROTEST GUN
VIOLENCE.
ORGANIZERS OF THE STUDENT LEAD
RALLIES ARE CALLING AT THE START
OF A MOVEMENT AND A WAKE-UP CALL
FOR CONGRESS.
>> THE PRESSURE IS ON FOR EVERY
PERSON IN POWER, AND IT WILL
STAY THAT WAY.
THEY KNOW WHAT IS COMING.
THEY KNOW THAT IF THERE IS NO
ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN PASSED THEN
WE WILL VOTE THEM OUT.
SPEAK OF THE LATEST FOX NEWS
POLL FOUND OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
FOR SPECIFIC GUN-CONTROL
MEASURES, INCLUDING 91% OF
VOTERS IN FAVOR OF UNIVERSAL
BACK CHECKS ON ALL GUN BUYERS.
72% SUPPORT RAISING THE MINIMUM
AGE TO BUY A GUN AND CONGRESS
INCLUDE SEVERAL REFORMS LAST
WEEK.
STRENGTHENING BACKGROUND CHECKS
AND PROVIDING FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
SAFETY MEASURES.
ACTIVISTS ARGUE IT'S NOT ENOUGH
AND DEMOCRATS ARE HOPING THAT
FRUSTRATION WILL HELP THEM IN
NOVEMBER.
>> THE ACTIVISM IN THE YOUNG
PEOPLE IS CHANGING THE EQUATION.
>> GUN CONTROL BE A COMPLICATED
ISSUE.
IN THE SENATE, DEMOCRATS ARE
DEFENDING SEATS IN STATES LIKE
WEST VIRGINIA, NORTH DAKOTA,
MISSOURI, INDIANA WHERE THERE IS
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> THEY HAVE TO BE CAREFUL ABOUT
EMBRACING GUN CONTROL ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL WHEN THEY ARE
GOING TO BE STATES AND DISTRICTS
THAT ARE NOT GOING TO GO FOR IT.
>> RETAKEN THE HOUSE WILL BE
EASY FOR DEMOCRATS EITHER.
THE LATEST FOX NEWS POLL FOUND A
TIGHTENING RACE IN CANDIDATE
PREFERENCES WITH 46% SAYING THEY
BACKED THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE
IN THEIR DISTRICT COMPARED TO 41
FOR THE REPUBLICAN.